this is a special report from cbs news
now to breaking news from london
buckingham palace has just confirmed
that prince philip the husband of queen
elizabeth has died at the age of 99.
he was recently as you know released
from the hospital after heart operation
mark phillips has this story
his role in life was to walk one step
behind the queen
but even back there prince philip was
able to carve out his own reputation and
role in history
elizabeth was the sharp window of what
philip famously called the royal firm
but he reputedly ran the businesses back
rooms
so essentially the queen has always worn
the crown
giles brandrith ran one of phillips
charities for years
and prince philip was allowed to wear
the trousers that's the way it worked
philip had been born into the greek
royal family in 1921
and was educated and had a naval career
in britain
and by luck or many think by royal
design
he was chosen to escort the young
princess elizabeth on a tour
the queen's cousin margaret rhodes
recalled the impression he made
in a conversation before she died
several years ago
and of course prince philip was the most
utterly good-looking
viking god
well he really was so good-looking a
dream royal romance
became a spectacularly successful royal
marriage
she provided the continuity and the
smiles
phillip provided the support and from
time to time
the controversy some thought he was a
gaff-prone fountain
of political incorrectness he once asked
aboriginals in australia whether they
still
threw spears at each other he told
british students in china
they would get slitty eyes if they
stayed there too long
closer to home he once asked scottish
driving instructors
how they kept their students off the
sauce long enough to pass the test
he just said what he felt he was very
funny prince philip was the man who said
if ever you see a man
opening the car door for his wife it's
either a new car
or a new wife he was a shrewd observer
and a shrewd operator credited with
diffusing the great royal crisis around
princess diana's funeral
it was philip who convinced princess
william and harry
to walk behind their mother's coffin
when they didn't want to
i'll walk with you he said harry has
since
said it was a traumatic experience no
child should have to endure
but it was a lesson in royal duty
royals don't gush except sometimes we
don't know what philip thought of the
queen's tribute to him on their golden
wedding anniversary
but it could serve as his epitaph he has
quite simply
been my strength and stay all these
years
and i and his whole family and
this and many other countries owe him a
debt
greater than he would ever claim or we
shall ever know
the royal family made the announcement
in a tweet this morning it is with deep
sorrow that her majesty the queen has
announced the death of her beloved
husband his royal highness
for the prince philip duke of edinburgh
he passed away peacefully this morning
at windsor castle we're joined now by
charlie daggett
in london charlie it was quite a life
it was quite a life you know he was
known to be such a character here in the
uk
um as the queen had put it multiple
times uh
she always described him as her rock
sort of the quiet uh strength behind the
throne
known for his personality his sense of
humor
uh his sometimes inappropriate comments
and a sense of humor and that was part
of parcel
of who he was but he was also known to
have
tried to be the peacemaker within the
royal family trying to keep the royal
family together
um through the rocky patches including
recent rocky patches um you know in a
way
the queen is obviously the matriarch of
this family but he served as the
patriarch of the family
uh when it comes to the royal family
itself um
but we were always on guard for you know
phillips gaffes prince phillips gaffes
what he
may have had to say and he was very
quick-witted
and as i said at times inappropriate as
mark pointed out in that obituary
he just left the hospital on march 16th
he had been in the hospital for a month
he underwent heart surgery so you know
there were there were hopes of course
that he was going to reach his 100th
birthday which is
june 10th the big celebrations planned
for that but
um yes we got news just moments ago from
the palace
i know charlie it's so sorry i'm so sad
to hear this news i know
as you pointed out he was at the
hospital and when he was released
people were feeling really good they
were thinking he's getting better listen
i know when you're 99
it's always you never know how much
longer you have but people were feeling
pretty good when he left the hospital
have you heard anything about exactly
what happened was it just
natural causes and i realize it's still
early in this story is just breaking
there
yeah gail you know i think we we all had
a sense of relief
when a person is old as he is goes to
the hospital
99 years old and then spends about a
month in the hospital and undergoes
a heart procedure you know you're not
thinking it's going to turn out
great so we're all surprised pleasantly
surprised when he left as you saw in his
own steam is
in the back of a car sitting up you know
it wasn't an ambulance that brought him
away
uh in terms of you know whether they
knew he was nearing the end and he'd be
more comfortable you know passing away
at home we don't know we don't know
exactly what he succumbed to
or when we just get that statement from
the
from the palace just moments ago so we
don't know the details yet but yes as we
as we know it passed away peacefully
this morning at windsor castle
yeah hey charlie you know it says in the
announcement that the uh
the royal family put out that the
website is temporarily unavailable as
they make changes and in addition they
note and i guess more information will
be forthcoming that they will join
people around the world in mourning this
loss i'm curious is there a playbook or
official process that will unfold in the
in the days ahead has something been
triggered that we can
point to well it's it's a good question
tony
there is and there certainly was but
uh in these days of covid um everything
has had to
uh been changed and everything has been
sort of marginalized so in terms of
what we can expect over the next two
days i don't know yet
the palace hasn't given us a
play-by-play it would have been a state
ceremony obviously for
for prince philip i don't know exactly
the timings for that or the level of
involvement but yes he will be
certainly mourned here and people will
want to show their morning
so there'll have to be something to mark
his passing and his funeral but exactly
what
i haven't got the details of charlie we
talk about what a colorful character he
was
i recall back in the mid 1980s when i
was based in london
going to a coaching contest he loved to
write
the prince loved to ride horse and
carriages in in competition
and i he was on the course that day in
competition and i you could hear him
cursing
all the way around the course very
loudly
you don't forget something like that
that's part of the charm
you just didn't quite know what he was
gonna say no he
he was never shy uh he was a character
and as you saw from those
earlier pictures you know when he was
younger he was quite the playboy i mean
he was
really the heartthrob in the early days
my wife
and her mother more appropriately would
talk about how handsome he was and how
charming he was
and yes part of the charm was you know
in these days of correct political
correctness i have to add there um he
was politically incorrect and we're
always waiting
for what he had to say and he you know i
mean
he was pretty uh vulgar and cutting with
uh some journalists the ones he didn't
like
he made known because you know
microphones were everywhere so
you know he was he was known to be uh a
man who painted outside the lines
uh nobody could really tell him what to
do except her majesty
and she wasn't about to do that so
really he was a law unto himself and
and beloved for that uh here in the uk
of course when he made these
inappropriate statements that you saw in
mark's obituary there
it is offensive and it's unacceptable
but it is who he was and he didn't
change for anybody
and let's talk about their long marriage
charlie they had been together for well
over 70 years
that's that in itself is extraordinary
it's legendary yeah and and i think
you know not just 70 years but really 70
years
on the throne you know he has been there
with the queen
with this unprecedented amount of time
right beside her
so he has had a duty a sense of
responsibility not just being married
for
for that long but being married to the
queen
and having that official role and that
duty being under the spotlight
having to go through uh the situation
with princess diana uh
dying having to be the peacemaker even
recently you know with uh with uh
prince harry and prince william prince
charles and everything that's gone on
with the royal family
he has been involved i know that for a
fact as of about a year ago when
when they were talking about mexi as it
were we know that he was part of those
conversations so he's very
very dynamic individual and one who
remained dynamic right up till the end
and he had to play a very unusual role
charlie i mean he's he's not the monarch
he's the spouse of the monarch
but but in many ways he's the head of
the family so he has this very fine line
he has to walk sometimes
well exactly right i mean he still had a
boss
maybe we all do his boss was and uh her
majesty the queen
but he had a role as a father and he had
a role
uh in bringing up uh prince charles you
know
he was bringing up a future king and uh
his grandson also a future king and his
role was valued and he was respected
within the royal family
because of that he always stood beside
beside uh the queen always knew his
place in a manner of speaking that he
was there to support her
charlie thank you